يعني يبدو يبدو المتظاهرون الان قد وصلوا
بالفعل الى شارع الحبيبه
كما قلناهما الان في المكان المعتاد الذي
تنظم فيه جبهه الخلاص دائما تحركاتها ليس
جبهه الخلاص وحده وانما اطراف عديده
سياسيه ومدنيه
وحقوقيه الاسبوع الماضي هنا في نفس المكان
كانت جمعيات مدنيه وحقوقيه قد نظمت تحركا
احتجاجيا ضد الحمله التي
تعيشها تونس ضد المهاجرين من افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء ايضا في هذا المكان وفي هذا
الشارع امس الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
كان قد قاد مسيره انطلقت من مقره الرئيسي
بالعاصمه تونس الى هذا المكان واليوم
يتجدد الموعد في الشارع مع تظاهره اخرى
ومع تحرك احتجاجي اخر عنوانه هو الاحتجاج
على الاعتقالات السياسيه الحاصله خلال
فتره الاخيره وعنوانه المطالبه باطلاق
سراح المعتقلين من قبل جبهه الخلاص هذه
المره وكنت اقول قبل قليل عثمان وسلمى
بانهم من المرات القليله التي تعيش فيها
تونس تحركات احتجاجيه ليومين متتاليين
تحركات بهذا الحجم وان اختلفت الجهات التي
دعت الى هذه
اليوم جبهه الخلاص